[Applaudissements]
le fessier regarde était de faire comme
ça voilà de quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi
c'est la ouate wallonie
la médaille a fait une attaque de taper
sur cette boîte vous avez une minute
ouais t'as une minute oui ça va mettez
les mains arrêté ne mettez pas les pieds
non n'allez pas les dix mois marc
olivier vachon
ça va gagner un téléphone est loyal et
des choses c'est parti valérie à décines
mettez vos mains attend les
téléspectateurs voient de quoi il s'agit
alemanno j'attaque a beau dire il ya
donc des papiers ou les récupérer moi
j'ai franchement je ne serai pas non
mais sérieux c'est ce qu'il ya de pire
c'est vrai pas lésiné dans les vallées
je dirais qu'elle est important je ne
donnerai pas le cadeau je donnerai c'est
chaud là les grès relâché sans pression
avec koné avec moi venait trop grande
polyvalence mais maintenant oui vous
touche à la vallée nouvelle adaptation
touché à l'aîné
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
moi je veux bien leur nom mais vous
allez je rajoute des trente secondes et
sera la dernière j'ai mis les mains d'or
mais vous êtes la paix après m'être les
gens je m'appelle la mata me lâche
on s'est enfoncé n'y aura pas une
seconde de plus qu'à orly alors on y va
il s'est dit touché du bas tu vas aller
chercher des trucs aller voilà nos
portes il est parti
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'amant je râle mais non mais
allez les gars y allez on y va aller
taper par l'éditeur date à la série est
égale excuse moi car on va te faire
perdre parle pour toi caroline je vais
pas m'emballer
voilà
[Rires]
valérie il avait fait perdre encore est
ce que vous les mettez vos mains mettez
vos mains mais donnez-moi vos mains
donnez-moi l'hôpital j'aime pas qui me
touche mais seul un art est à l'étude
oui mais c'est pour aller on est à
l'aise ta main et manu mais ça c'est
l'animal mais c'est l'animal est à
laquelle bien
[Applaudissements]
cette année sa douleur